bonsoir thomas le suspense continue donc
de votre côté
[Musique]
les médias américains actualise assez
régulièrement ces dernières heures les
résultats dans des états tels que la
pennsylvanie où la géorgie dans ces deux
états il affirme que désormais je baille
donne est en tête une courte avance sur
donald trump par exemple en géorgie il
affirme que le démocrate et une avance
d'à peine mille voix sur son concurrent
c'est pour cette raison que l'état va
procéder à un recomptage des votes
écouter le secrétaire d'état de la
géorgie qui s'est exprimé il ya quelques
heures à 10 heures du matin il restait
un peu moins de 1500 voix a compté dans
les comtés de gwyneth floyd cherokee et
cob
en outre il reste 8890 bulletins de vote
militaires en suspens qui seront contées
s'ils parviennent avant la fermeture des
bureaux aujourd'hui à l'heure actuelle
les résultats en géorgie reste trop
serré pour pouvoir trancher alors que
nous nous rapprochons d'un décompte
final nous pouvons commencer à envisager
la prochaine étape avec une marge assez
fine il y aura un recomptage ans georges
ce qui concerne la pennsylvanie les
médias américains estiment que bae donne
est devant avec désormais douze mille
voix d'avancé une bascule qui s'explique
notamment par le dépouillement tardive
des bulletins par correspondance ainsi
que des votes par anticipation notamment
dans la ville de philadelphie qui votent
traditionnellement démocrate val tron
conteste le dépouillement dans cette
ville qu'il la qualité sur twitter il ya
quelques heures comme une ville qui je
cite à une histoire pour i concernant
l'intégrité des élections alors certains
médias affirment que si les résultats
dans ces deux états la pennsylvanie et
la géorgie était confirmée le pont
proclamé la victoire de joe biden car il
lui suffit un seul état une seule
victoire dans un de ces deux états lui
suffirait pour atteindre les 270
l'écueil des lecteurs on surveille aussi
les résultats dans le nevada où bailon
est également annoncée en tête
écoutez aussi nancy pelosi chef des
démocrates du congrès qui a donné une
conférence de presse il ya quelques
heures elle parle déjà de joe biden
comme du président élu ce matin il est
clair que l'équipe by john harris va
gagner la maison blanche
son élection est historique porté par le
plus grand scrutin de l'histoire de
notre pays
73 8 millions d'américains le plus grand
nombre de votes jamais enregistré par
aucune élection américaine dans
l'histoire
le président-élu byden devra mener un
mandat fort et il aura une chambre des
représentants à majorité démocrate
solide à ses côtés et puis cette
information importante je baille donne
va s'exprimer ce soir ce sera
certainement aux alentours de 20h heure
américaine on verra si c'est pour
proclamer sa victoire lors de cette
affaire prise de parole on se rappelle
que joe biden avait s'était dit
conscient mais avait demandé à ses bras
ses soutiens d'être patient avant de
pouvoir annoncer sa victoire et puis de
son côté donc donald trump continue de
revendiquer lui aussi la victoire tout
en accusant certains de vouloir lui
voler l'élection la dre une conférence
de presse hier une allocution qui a été
coupé en plein direct par un certain
nombre de médias qui ont accusé le
président de divulguer de fausses
informations de sur des accusations de
fraudes notamment va suivre donc
attentivement les prochaines prises de
parole notamment celle de joe biden et
puis on verra comment réagira le
locataire de la maison blanche au
discours de l'ancien vice président
merci thomas pour toutes ces précisions
comme abonnés en direct de washington